[Musique]
chaque année de nouvelles drogues de
nouvelles molécules apparaissent sur le
marché noir
il n'existe aucune structure légale au
québec pour tester ces substances
[Musique]
et ce alors que le pays est aux prises
avec une épidémie surdose sans précédent
plus que jamais visité les paradis
artificiels relève de la roulette russe
j'ai suivi deux médecins qui veulent
faire bouger les choses
il propose des services d'analysé en
marge du système
on vient juste d'arriver à timeless j'ai
l'impression que beaucoup de gens ici
qui vont manquer de sommeil en fin de
semaine
[Musique]
le festival timeless regroupe plus de
2000 amateurs de musique électronique à
sainte agathe de lotbinière le temps
d'un week-end l'organisation ne se le
cache pas une bonne partie des
festivaliers consomment des drogues
la docteure marie ève morin elle-même
budget a créé le projet caméléon qui
offre un service d'analysé de substance
et d'information ce conseil c'est qu'à
l'heure actuelle on peut trouver des
fentes année dans la cocaïne dans la mdm
a dans la méthamphétamine mind à la
kétamine donc le pantanal c'est présent
c'est la manipuler des drogues pour en
faire l'analyse est illégal à moins
d'obtenir une exemption de santé canada
le projet qu'a millions en a fait la
demande au mois de février dernier mais
la docteure morin est toujours sans
nouvelle jusqu'à présent ce privilège
n'est accordée qu'à certains centres
d'injection supervisés au pays donc si
c'est la tante du projet caméléon
c'est ici que les gens viennent tester
leur drogue
et comme vous allez pouvoir le voir ben
les intervenants qui travaillent ici ont
des moyens assez limité
[Musique]
douze mois d'août
on
[Musique]
pas de fin d'année les duels demeure
parce que tu voulais amuse-toi bien fait
quand même attention aux bipèdes bord de
l'eau dr morin avance que les bénévoles
du projet caméléon ne manipule aucune
substance prohibée
ce sont plutôt les utilisateurs qui
déposent leurs échantillons avant qu'un
intervenant procès d'août est souvent on
entend ouais mais ils s'en foutent un
peu de leur santé non ils s'en foutent
pas de leur santé c'est bien pour ça
qu'il faut tester aussi parce qu'ils en
ont à [ __ ] de leur santé et keith vaz
aimerait savoir ce qu'ils attendent
comme les drogues sont pas régulés mort
peut pas savoir ce qu'il ya dedans
nous on fait ce qu'on peut avec ce que
la loi nous permet de faire de ce qu'on
fait là c'est de la santé la sécurité
publique
la sûreté du québec pourtant présentes
sur le site du festival timeless affirme
ne pas être au courant de ce type de
service il n'en demeure pas moins que
sans exemption de santé canada les
consommateurs qui se présentent dans la
tente du projet caméléon risque d'être
arrêté pour possession de drogue
en mai 2018 le gouvernement du québec
donnait le feu vert à une étude de
faisabilité pour éventuellement
permettre un projet pilote d'analystes
de drogue
le programme subventionné par santé
canada et géré par l'institut
universitaire sur les dépendances qui a
refusé nos demandes d'entrevue
mais plus d'un an après son annonce
aucune drogue n'a été testé sur le
terrain pour la docteure marie ève morin
la situation est trop urgente pour
attendre est ce que pour un risque d'un
faux sentiment de sécurité
une fois qu'ils ont fait tester leur
drogue vivent leurs étals sans bord
voire de fentanyl ou drogue
potentiellement dangereux les gens qui
consomment qui ont qu'on analyse des
substances c'est parce qu'ils pensent y
en a quand même une bonne partie qui ne
consommeront fort
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'en festival
les gens sont là pour s'amuser
la plupart vont consommer de toute façon
[Musique]
depuis 15 ans en colombie britannique
les autorités tolèrent quant à eux
l'analyse de drogue au festival de
musique électronique shambala le
gouvernement de la province a d'ailleurs
annoncé en juin 2010 est un programme
d'intervention contre la crise des
opioïdes qui inclut notamment l'analyse
de substance depuis deux ans accuse
l'organisme qui teste la drogue à
shambala acquis la technologie de
spectrométrie de masse qui permet
d'identifier précisément les molécules
qui composent les substances les
analyses colorimétrique offertes par le
projet caméléon sont quant à elles
plutôt approximatif on a les résultats
quand même super vite en quelques
secondes dans les airs bardon levée d
avantage c'est qu'on peut pas dire tout
ce qui à danser ça arrive souvent qu'on
soit là chez parce que tu as dans ta
poudre jeu c'est parti
[Musique]
donc c'est quoi sa clio partie
congélateur
ce sont des urines dont on l'attend le
résultat loin de la musique des
festivals à la clinique centaines
d'outils de saint girons le dr
jean-robert analyses d'urines de ses
patients consommateurs de drogues depuis
deux ans
il a ainsi une meilleure connaissance de
ce qui se transige dans sa région les
laurentides
le pionnier de la médecine communautaire
travaille avec les plus démunis de la
province depuis plus de 50 ans a lancé
le numéro de code quand ça reste blanc
un beau c'est qu'il ya probablement de
janvier 2016 à décembre 2018 plus de
onze mille cinq cents personnes sont
décédées de surdoses depuis est du pays
c'est la première cause de mortalité
chez les 30-39 ans avec la crise qui
sévit au canada il est plus important
que jamais de savoir ce qui se consomme
sur le terrain selon le dr robert
depuis octobre 2010 est la clinique a
donc fait parvenir près de 2700
échantillons d'urines au centre de
toxicologie du québec
elle en tire est une banque de données
unique au québec sur la réalité de la
consommation de drogues
je trouve simplement appliqué
le principe de fonctionnement de la
santé communautaire c'est d'agir
immédiatement de faire ce qu'il faut
pour protéger des vies
donc pour se renseigner sur qui
circulent dans le milieu rien de mieux
que les urines des consommateurs mais
depuis le mois d'août le centre intégré
de santé et de services sociaux de laval
qui assumait les coûts a décidé de
cesser de financer ces tests il en
coûtait 75 dollars par analyse pour un
total de près de cent cinquante mille
dollars depuis octobre 2007
omnisys c'est très bien ce que vous
faites c'est au continuer cet album job
c'est utile blablabla mais on n'a pas de
sous entre temps le docteur robert
continue de prélever des échantillons
d'urines qu'il congèle espérant pouvoir
éventuellement les envoyer au centre de
toxicologie du québec
parallèlement la clinique centaine ici
procède elle aussi à une demande
d'exemption auprès de santé canada pour
faire de l'analyse de drogue en bonne et
due forme
on est ici dans une situation
de mortalité éthiquement je ne peux pas
attendre avant de rendre des services et
sauver les vies grâce à ces analyses
d'urines le médecin d'ailleurs identifié
de nombreux comprimé contaminés au fin
d'année on a sauvé six vit on est en
train de favoriser les mortalités par
surdose par ignorance donc on nous prive
de l'outil de véritable prévention
[Musique]
i